[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight Bernie Sanders is running for
president again not that he ever really
stopped Sanders announced his second
campaign this morning in a 10-minute
video before you drop everything and
watch it take half a moment to
appreciate just how much America and the
Democratic Party have changed over the
past four years
pull up Sanders his first presidential
announcement speech it was May 26th 2015
in Burlington Vermont Sanders looked a
lot different then but the second thing
you'll notice if you watch it is how
familiar his words sound it's spooky
virtually all of the themes in Sanders
his announcement speech is first one are
what in the end got Donald Trump elected
president the collapse the middle class
the crushing cost of health care and
student loans the pointlessness of
perpetual war in the Middle East the
distorting effect of Washington
lobbyists and donors the swamp the
dangers of corporate power the need for
better jobs and higher wages for
Americans the generational disaster that
is our trade policy it's all there
everything but build a wall Sanders has
often described as the 1970s era
socialist and that's basically true he
honeymooned to the Soviet Union he looks
like he combs his hair with a balloon
but if you listen carefully what Bernie
Sanders was really selling in the last
campaign was not Marxism it was economic
populism and an awful lot of people
agreed with it many of them wind up
voting for Donald Trump in the general
election in case you've forgotten here's
what Bernie Sanders sounded like back
then I am fighting to break up the large
banks on Wall Street but I do want the
opportunity to tell them face-to-face
what their greed and illegal behavior
has done to this country if Wall Street
does not end its greed we will end it
for them well you could disagree about
whether Wall Street and the big banks
are really driving America's decline
like all politicians Sanders was and is
an oversteer but looking back there was
something touchingly old-fashioned of
out the way Bernie Sanders ran that
campaign Sanders made no appeal at all
to interest groups he explicitly opposed
interest groups he instead talked about
national unity and the people left
behind his first announcement speech did
not mention the words racism or sexism
or for that matter abortion or gun
control he said nothing about
immigration or non-citizens Sanders was
running for Americans all of them
whether you agree with him or not
needless to say Sanders quickly found
himself at war with Democrats the modern
Democratic Party has no place for the
idea of nationhood it rejects the
existence of universal interests and
values instead of a common American
culture Democrats see only tribes now
Bernie Sanders is pushing 80 and he
seems completely bewildered by these
changes in attitude in the weeks after
the 2016 election Sanders told one
reporter that Hillary Clinton lost the
race because quote it's not good enough
to say I am a woman vote for me well
Sanders was right obviously but he was
way too late modern Democrats are
defined by identity politics that's the
idea that the accident of your birth
determines what you're worth your value
some groups are favored others are
blamed and punished what matters isn't
what you do the choices that you make
what matters is who you are genetically
by the time Brett Kavanaugh was
nominated the Supreme Court six months
ago Democrats had made this entirely
explicit women across this nation should
be outraged at what these white men
senators are doing to this woman this is
all gross strategizing from 11 old white
men it's a white man strategy that is
politically dumb in my opinion these
people in Congress right now and that
Senate Judiciary Committee these white
men old by the way I'm not protecting
women old white men not a favored group
in the modern Democratic Party to put it
mildly
and yet Bernie Sanders is undeniably all
three of those things so how do you win
the nomination of a party that hates you
for qualities you can't change Bernie
Sanders is not the only Democrat facing
this dilemma far from it nor is he the
only way
to realize that there's really only one
solution you have to embrace identity
politics getting woke is the only option
so Bernie Sanders has done just that
here's a clip from his second
presidential announcement video released
today our campaign is about transforming
our country and creating a government
based on the principles of economic
social racial and environmental justice
our campaign is about redoubling our
efforts to end racism sexism homophobia
religious bigotry and all forms of
discrimination so that's the new Bernie
Sanders and he seems a lot smaller than
the old version instead of saving
America from predatory global capitalism
Sanders plans to save us from Donald
Trump's racism and sexism okay let's say
he does that what then racism and sexism
aren't actually the biggest problems
that America faces sorry
not even close actually growing economic
stratification and a dying middle class
those are the biggest problems but
nobody in Washington wants to talk about
those things and why would they people
in Washington are richer than ever
any change the status quo is a threat to
them by definition it's much better for
them to have the population squabble
over unresolvable questions of identity
a nation that's arguing about skin color
is not asking how a tiny group of people
is now flying private well almost
everybody else has gotten poorer so
identity politics is a tactic designed
to prevent
conversations dangerous to the ruling
class obviously it's also a way for some
of the most privileged people in America
to recast themselves as victims Cory
Booker for example Cory Booker went to
Stanford Oxford and Yale his parents
were IBM executives Booker has spent
most of his career in the Senate
carrying water for his fellow privileged
people his peers on Wall Street
privileged yeah Cory Booker defines that
word now that he's running for president
he'll be interesting to hear Cory Booker
explain why he has allowed his friends
in the finance world to continue to pay
half the tax rate that you're probably
paying now but he likely doesn't want to
talk about that
instead it probably spent most of his
time talking about racism including the
races and he has personally experienced
as a powerless person a powerless person
who went to Stanford Oxford and Yale and
whose parents were IBM executives so you
can see what's going on here this is a
scam a dummy politics is a scam and it's
not so different from the one that
Jesse's smile at just pulled smollett is
a rich actor with a hit TV show that's
fine we used to call people like that
pampered but smart doesn't want to be
thought of as a pampered nobody does
really so he recast himself as a victim
the people oppressing him he told us
were Trump voters badly educated thugs
from some rural backwater probably
inbreds you've never read a book people
who don't have camera Harris's personal
cell phone number people who probably
don't even believe in global warming or
like Thai food those people they're the
problem they must be crushed
somehow the left is telling us the weak
are now oppressing the strong that's
their claim the old left would have
pushed back against this they would have
felt some sympathy for the people our
economy has left behind but not anymore
the new left Revere's Cory Booker and
Barack Obama they're rallying behind
Jesse Smollett when sports fraud was
exposed they defended him without saying
so believe me he feel coming out I'm
gonna withhold until all the information
actually comes out from on the record
sources I think that the facts are still
unfolding once the investigation is
concluded then we can all comment but
I'm not going to comment and tell
another the outcome of the investigation
so no one who could admit that Jesse
Smollett is not a victim
he's a rich guy who played the victim
and blamed other people nobody's asked
for any Sanders about that story yet but
he probably say the same thing he has to
say that it's required now